la sphère du jour on a appris
aujourd'hui que sort ayari fille une
jeune femme qui était venue pour les 35
heures de baba à l'époque porté plainte
contre jean michel maire pour agression
sexuelle
et comme on se dit tout bas forcément on
va tout vous expliquer parce qu'on est
obligé de revenir là dessus c'est une
séquence qui avait fait parlé il ya deux
ans sur le prime t pmp des défis son
permis pendant les 35 heures sont ryan
jeune femme de 22 ans était venu sur le
plateau et pendant un défi jean michel
avait eu un geste envers cette femme qui
avait beaucoup fait parler un geste
déplacé d'ailleurs on l'avait dit à
l'antenne et jean michel avait pour défi
de l'embrasser celle ci avait refusé et
jean michel lui avait l'avant voilà un
avant bras c'est sur la poitrine
à l'époque cette affaire dont qui avait
fait beaucoup de bruit et jean michel
vous vous étiez expliqué là-dessus et
vous étiez très est déjà à l'époque
regarde vous étiez extrêmement peiné ce
week-end et même maintenant agent me mon
coeur oui c'est vrai que ça bassam hans
a même laissé genre connaît surtout de
la violence des mots je crois à
respecter les femmes autant je peux que
je suis un gros lourd sagelat vous
aisément s'il ce geste a été déplacée
comme j'ai cru comprendre je m'en excuse
une nouvelle fois sur le moment c'est
vrai que j'ai pas saisie du tout la
portée de la portée de la chose après
c'est vrai que le terme d'agression
savamment choquer je m'en excuse une
nouvelle fois voilà j'ai eu ces mots
d'ordre des fidji montereau un peu qu'on
voit là et donc la jeune femme et qui
est même venu sur le plateau pour
s'expliquer sur cette affaire
elle nous avait déclaré qu'elle n'irait
pas porté plainte regardez et jean
michel vous allez nous dire on sait on
aujourd'hui parce que les
téléspectateurs veulent savoir c'est un
bateau j'ai trouvé le geste de jean
michel maire un peu déplacées et pas
très professionnel après si je suis là
aujourd'hui c'est parce que non mais
j'ai le marbre quand même présenter des
excuses que j'ai accepté tout le monde
donne vie et dépose plainte attaque le
donc moi j'ai pris la décision de ne pas
des brèves de ne pas déposer plainte
justement si aujourd'hui je dépose pas
plainte c'est parce que voilà j'aime pas
le conflit je suis vraiment invitant la
presse qu' est-ce que c'est ce que vous
sinon vous auriez déposé plainte sinon
je n'ai pas être portés alors jean-mi où
ça en est aujourd'hui assez rapidement
racontez nous l'histoire
sarah en est que je pensais que la
sphère était un peu bas fini parce que
j'avais présenté mes excuses et voilà je
vais leur faire bien sûr et là j'ai
appris la semaine en fin de semaine
dernière la pole au commissariat de
boulogne m'a appelé pour me dire qu'elle
avait déposée que soraya riffier avait
déposé plainte pour agression sexuelle
et donc du coup j'ai été con
ok par la police entendu vu par un
psychiatre donc maintenant je sais pas
où ça peut-être aller au tribunal je
sais pas encore ça dépend si la plaindre
la plainte est reçue recevable et après
il y aurait une instruction pour
l'instant on est dans les auditions
voilà et place on comprend les chais pas
trop bien compris parce que je l'avais
eue au téléphone une fois après la faire
et on s'était expliqués largement elle
était plutôt même embêter des
rebondissements fait les conséquences de
mon acte très délicat tout ce qu'on
trouvait à jade me déplace les lourds
tout ce qu'on veut mais voilà elle
s'était expliqué en disant qu'elle m'en
voulez pas du tout au contraire essayer
de faire tout son possible pour essayer
que ça se calme parce qu'elle m'en
voulez pas que j'avais été correct avec
elle plutôt respectueux voilà et puis ma
là je sais pas pourquoi maintenant elle
a déposé plainte donc alors donc je
serai plus jamais eu j'ai jamais revu ni
au téléphone depuis un an et demi et la
vienne a déposé plainte
écoutez donc jour l'impact ça bien sûr
on espère que ça va ça va ça je respecte
cette fait ce qu'elle veut bien sûr la
loi mais nous l'avons nous nous tenir au
courant de cette affaire bien sûr et que
ça bouge mais c'est vrai que c'est sorti
aujourd'hui partout donc on est obligé
d'en sa voir l'explication de jean
michel et merci jean michel joux si vous
êtes très attristé encore par cette
affaire oui parce que vous croyez
voilà vous aimez c'est vrai que là ça
revient vezon après est forcément très
mal et ben merci en tout cas que vous
êtes expliqué là-dessus jean-michel
merci beaucoup